There's a kind of a cool gene that was just
Research discovered just a couple months ago the CAC gene
People that have defects in this gene this person has done have a much higher degree of sensitivity to e-imps
It's kind of neat
So I've had a lot of patients that have defects in the most genes
Absolutely not so the right helps with that
So if that e-imps you'd really talk to them about you have to really be careful to
groan your house
So I don't like spigot to using groves for the
for the for your band
That's a very that's a good piece to do but that's only groaning you while you're in bed
So you're not in bed all they love so where is your biggest source of e-imps coming from?
Well in the house it's coming from your electrical panel. It's coming from your biker wave
It's coming from your electrical equipment your television and your cell phone
Right
Where's the external e-imps coming from the biggest is from cell phone towers
uh smart meters yep
from high power lines
So all these are e-imps right
Our ancestors
built wigwabs on the ground and walked barefoot
Right, so you were constantly grounding yourself
Of course they didn't have spark meters and cell phone towers either
So we are insulting our body with electromagnetic frequencies that are
That are doing ill health to us
So they're at the frequency life that our hernitas
Whereas the true right is not at a frequency that's hurting us. It's not a frequency like that's helping us
So using the right is actually helping block e-imps
But you're not using the right point for hours today either
So you still have to do things like this is a brand new cell phone that I just got right
And I don't have my protection on there. We use a disk called a hydro disk
That's a company on a Wisconsin
But patient that uses another company that he really likes too
So there's some cell phone protectors that are really good
We use we use to ground people's houses with a product that is a ground basalt
That would help pull e-imps out in the house it was
He worked fairly well
Uh now we use this hydro it makes a whole house disk that we use that makes it a little easier for people
But it's still going to ground your house a salt simply has zero charge
River e-imps have a positive charge
The grove has a negative charge
So when you're grove to yourself and you're walking on the grove outside barefoot you're grove to yourself
That's why you feel better when you go walk the beach
So you're grove to yourself
That's why pets are good for you your dog is outside running around grove
Growning itself and you comb you pet it and you discharge all the positive electrons on your dog
I'm going outside and play again
That's why people feel better when they get out of horse
That's why horse therapy works so good the horse is standing on the floor grounded in hooks all day long
You put a child that's 80-80-80-80-80 if their head is just like spinning you put about a horse they settle down
Because you are discharging all that positive electrons that are not good for you